[Music]
so you've all had that moment where
you're at a bar you're maybe dancing a
little bit moving around you see someone
looking at you out of the corner of your
eye and then your movements become a
little more constricted you become a
little more in your head you're worried
about what they might think about you so
that's that external motivation in any
moment you can ask yourself am i doing
this because I want to or because I
think people will like it am I doing
think people will like it if we're
basing it off of the reality that
someone else will like it we'll never
really know we open ourselves up for
that social anxiety the fear of negative
judgment the unknown of external
validation so we can always ask
ourselves what do I want to do right now
what is interesting to me what would
feel good to me and act off of that to
eliminate social anxiety to bring more
confidence into our conversations so
that's how we find our authentic voice
and use it and your authentic voice is a
deep down understanding of who you are
what you care about
and what you believe and it's only when
we have that foundational understanding
that we're able to bring confidence into
social situations because if we're not
basing our actions off of this internal
understanding we're constantly looking
for external validation for other people
to tell us what is cool what is
acceptable what is appropriate and if
you look at the actual definition of
social anxiety it's literally the fear
of negative judgment so again it's based
in that external validation and I love
Carl Sagan who says we can judge our
progress by the courage of our questions
and the depth of our answers and so to
find our authentic voice we need to ask
ourselves these courageous questions ask
yourself what's the dream if I could not
fail what would I do with my time ask
yourself what am I not doing that I
would like to be ask yourself what is
most challenging for my for me right now
and we can trust questions in
conversation just ask yourself the last
time someone asked you a question
looked you in the eyes and listened to
you how did it feel
universally good it always will so
whenever we're asking questions we can
trust that we're learning and growing
and that we're leaving a good impression
and there's one simple question we can
ask ourselves to fundamentally transform
our
conversations so 60 seconds whether it's
going on a date whether it's going into
a big conference whatever it may be ask
yourself what am I most excited to learn
about the people that I will meet what
am I most excited to learn about the
people that I will meet so what you will
do is you will establish something I
call the curiosity compass you'll
establish a series of questions that are
authentic to you that you genuinely want
to ask these people and basically what
happens now is you're focusing more on
being interested than on being
interesting which is one of the oldest
techniques in the book to actually feel
more confident in social situations so
when you've identified your curiosity
compass it's much easier to exist with
anyone and feel comfortable and so
having these questions just lodged to
memory are gonna make you feel better
when you're in these social situations
and you know outside of the question of
what do I most want to learn about these
people I also think it's important for
people to think about what I call your
go-to questions and so your go-to
questions are three to five questions
but you generally always want to know to
people so this could be what are you
most excited about this could be what's
the dream what's your priority right now
what's the next big thing you have
coming up could be what's something
awesome you've learned recently and what
happens is you think of Yogi Berra the
amazing your New York Yankees catcher
and he used to say you can't think and
hit at the same time because hitting is
this incredibly fast just volatile act
and so once the ball comes out of that
hand it's coming into the batter's box
you're not thinking about it
everything your body has just been
trained to react to it and hit that ball
where you want it to go and so I think
that when you're in conversation there's
so many things that we can worry about
so many stories we can bring into it but
when we have those questions logged to
memory we're so much more likely to
bring those types of things into
conversation to lead us towards more
interesting conversations that we're
genuinely going to care about and
another powerful exercise that we can
practice for asking better questions is
something called the golden rule of
questions and we all know the golden
rule in life treat others the way that
you would like to be treated so the
golden rule of questions
ask questions to others that you would
like to be asked yourself if you just
take some time to identify here the
types of things that I would like to be
asked about here the types of things
that I want to talk about then now
you've also identified some of your
authentic passions personally in the
form of questions that you can give to
someone else so this golden rule of
questions is a great way so again
further deepen your understanding of the
questions that you want to be bringing
into conversation and any sort of
interpersonal situation
[Music]